Він здійснює складні та дорогі пластичні операції
в Німеччині. Але в Україні робить це безкоштовно.
Клаус Екснер з Франкфурта-на-Майні двічі на рік
приїздить до Львова, аби допомогти українським
дітям. Цього разу у 8-й міській лікарні
на нього чекали понад 70 маленьких пацієнтів.
Цього дворічного малюка Екснер оперував
уже кілька разів. І доведеться оперувати знову.
Більшість цих дітей від народження мають
різні вади з очима або обличчям.
Треба постійно тренувати око, тримати око ось так.
Надавати благодійну медичну допомогу
за кордоном - у родині Клауса це майже
сімейна традиція, яка пішла ще від його батька.
Брат Клауса - ортопед, дружина - теж пластичний
хірург і теж приїздить в Україну допомагати дітям.
Уперше Клаус Екснер відвідав Львів
під час "Євро-2012", приєднавшись
до гуманітарної акції німецьких уболівальників
"BigShoe". Їхня мета - привернути увагу
до відсутності повноцінного лікування дітей
у країнах, де проводяться футбольні чемпіонати
світу чи Європи.
Дуже, дуже багато людей перейняли цю ідею,
адже ми, я б сказав, нашим заможним життям
у Німеччині і взагалі в Західній Європі
багато чим маємо завдячувати іншим людям.
І ми зобов’язані допомагати цим людям.
Екснер є також членом Німецького об‘єднання
пластичних хірургів Interplast-Germany.
За майже 40 років свого існування ця організація
допомогла десяткам тисяч людей у країнах,
що розвиваються. Переїзди хірургів, матеріали
для операцій фінансують за рахунок пожертв.
Для пацієнтів усе безкоштовно. Віктор з Чернівців,
який привіз до лікаря Екснера свою доньку,
не приховує здивування.
У кожної людини свої принципи. Хоче добро людям
зробити, це ясно. Це можливо. Не з вигоди, це точно.
Від німецького колеги не відходять кілька лікарів
з різних регіонів України. Він охоче ділиться
досвідом, вважаючи це певною мірою своїм
внеском у медичну реформу в Україні. Спеціалістів,
які могли б допомогти дітям відкоригувати вади
зовнішності, в Україні дуже мало.
У нас не така сильна медицина, як за кордоном,
як в Європі.
Більше 8 годин за операційним столом, а тоді ще
нагляд за маленькими пацієнтами, чи все добре
після операції.І так - 4 дні поспіль.
Коли ввечері бачиш вісьмох дітей, які страждають,
це дуже непросто. Ти не можеш іти просто спати -
ти дивишся, питаєш, чи все в порядку, чи треба
щось зробити, чи достатньо знеболювального.
Під час останнього приїзду до Львова Клаус Екснер
зробив понад 20 операцій. І через півроку
хоче приїхати знову.